le Sénat c'est l'une des deux Chambres
du Parlement français il siège au Palais
du Luxembourg et avec l'Assemblée
nationale il détient le pouvoir
législatif
les deux assemblées du Parlement sont
chargés d'examiner et de voter les lois
de contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
d'évaluer les politiques publiques
contrairement à l'Assemblée nationale le
Sénat ne peut pas être dissout il est le
garant de la stabilité des institutions
et joue un rôle de contre-pouvoir
comme l'indique l'article 24 de la
Constitution le Sénat est chargé de
représenter les collectivités
territoriales en effet les 348 sénateurs
sont élus au suffrage universel indirect
par 162 000 grands électeurs parmi
lesquels on retrouve essentiellement les
mers et les élus municipaux
départementaux et régionaux de
l'hexagone et d'outre-mer
douce sénateurs représentent les
Français établis hors de France
pour être candidat aux élections
sénatoriales il faut avoir au minimum 24
ans et le plus jeune sénateur a été élu
à l'âge de 26 ans
la durée du mandat est de 6 ans et tous
les trois ans le Sénat est renouvelé par
moitié ce qui assure une continuité dans
ses choix et ses orientations
au fil des élections la part des femmes
élues sénatrices a fortement augmenté
le président du Sénat est le deuxième
personnage de l'État c'est lui qui
assure l'intérim lorsque le président de
la République n'est plus en mesure
d'assumer ses fonctions dans l'hémicycle
les sénateurs sont placés selon leur
groupe et leur orientation politique
c'est dans ce lieu emblématique que son
prise toutes les décisions concernant
les textes de loi
chaque sénateur est membre d'une
commission permanente
mais il peut aussi faire partie de l’une
des délégations du Sénat ou de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques
le contrôle du gouvernement et
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
est l'autre grande mission du Sénat ce
contrôle s'exerce en séance publique et
de façon permanente par le travail des
commissions et des délégations ces
travaux donnent lieu à de nombreuses
auditions et à des déplacements sur le
terrain
les commissions d'enquête permettent de
se saisir des sujets les plus graves les
personnes entendues doivent prêter
serment et les sénateurs disposent de
véritables pouvoirs d'investigation
les conclusions tirées de ces enquêtes
émissions permettent de proposer de
nouvelles pistes pour réformer le pays
sur le site internet du Sénat vous
pouvez retrouver tous les éléments pour
suivre l'examen des textes la séance en
direct le travail des commissions les
rapports dessinateurs et bien d'autres
ressources encore
le Sénat consultent régulièrement les
citoyens et les élus locaux pour nourrir
ses travaux vous pouvez également
déposer ou soutenir une pétition en
ligne pour demander au Sénat de faire
évoluer la loi ou de lancer un contrôle
le Sénat est également ouvert aux
visiteurs plus de 250 000 personnes
viennent chaque année visiter le Palais
du Luxembourg notamment pendant les
Journées Européennes du Patrimoine vous
pouvez également retrouver l'actualité
du Sénat sur les réseaux sociaux YouTube
Twitter Facebook Instagram Tik Tok et
LinkedIn